Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube và Excel bài số 5
hành điều kiện ít và men Hà Nho trước
khi vào bài 5 thì mình sẽ giải bài tập
của bài số 4 hôm trước nhé Ok bài số 4
hôm trước là kết quả thi cuối quá Ở đây
bây giờ mình cần diện mình cần tính là
số thí sinh động tức là điểm trung bình
lớn hơn bằng Sáu đúng không đấy thì ở
đây mình phải đến rồi đúng không có nên
là số thí sinh thì mình phải đến rồi
nhưng mà lại là số thí sinh đậu quá Thế
là mình phải đếm có điều kiện như video
Mình nói rồi các bạn có thể dùng làm cao
ít hoặc KW nhé
cho ví dụ mình tất cả là cos đi lại ấn
mũi tên xuống này các bạn tác thì đầu
tiên là cái vùng điều kiện Đúng không
các bạn sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ trên vùng
điều kiện của điểm trung bình người đã
lấy cần phải điều kiện là diện lớn nước
lọc bằng 6 loa cả các bạn sẽ bỏ qua phép
các bạn sẽ ghi lại diện lớn hơn hoặc
bảng 6 các bạn đóng ngoặc kép lại các
bạn đó đơn gọi enter thì như vậy là có 5
thí sinh mà lớn hơn bằng 60 Ok sang công
thứ 2 là diện số thí sinh rất là nhóm 6
luôn thế là nó ngược lại với kia các bạn
vẫn bằng ca ghép này các bạn tát nhá thì
đầu tiên các bạn bôi lên toàn bộ cái
vùng điện trung bình ở đây đúng không
cần phải là các bạn mở két ra cậu CV là
diện nhỏ hơn 6 Họ sẽ đóng và kéo lại còn
đó còn đơn ạ Đấy Như vậy là có 3 thí
sinh lấy 3 thí sinh là thiện một này các
bạn giữ gần chôn nhớ hai này ba này có 3
bạn này là nhỏ hơn 6A
a tiếp theo là diện số thí sinh có điểm
trung bình lớp 8 Thì cái này nó cũng
giống như là thí sinh đậu rồi nhá đấy
các bạn cũng bằng các em mình Tát nữa
các bạn Bôi đen toàn bộ vùng điện trung
bình này là các bạn phải là còn mở các
em à còn ghi là diện lớn hơn hoặc bằng 8
+ đóng ngoặc kép dấu ngoặc đơn này là
như vậy có một thí sinh luôn đúng không
Đây thí sinh này đâu số thí sinh đậu và
điểm Pixel lớn nước năm lại như vậy cô
này là có hai điều kiện được Điều kiện
thứ nhất là động cơ và điều kiện thứ hai
là điểm Excel và lớn lắm đúng không Tại
sao bằng này kbps đầu tiên là cái cùng
Điều kiện thứ nhất là đậu chứ còn mua
đèn cái điện cho mình này đấy vẫn phải
các bạn mở két ra có ghi là diện lớn hơn
hoặc bằng Sáu đúng không cho nó hoặc các
bạn như vậy các bạn so với phấn đấu rồi
đó cần phải là cái vùng điều kiện thứ
hai là cái niệm Pixel đó các bạn Bôi đen
toàn bộ cái vùng để video là cần phải
rồi sao lớn mùng 5 mũi nhọn mỏ két là nó
ghi là lớn hơn 5 điều kiện là lớn hơn
năm rồi các bạn nó hoặc
Em hãy gọi enter như vậy có 4 thí sinh
thôi tiếp theo là điện số thí sinh đậu
này để đi xe lớn hơn 5 và word là lớn
nước 8 quá đây là ba điều kiện rồi nhé
Đời Gọi bụng bằng trang web này à
có điều kiện thứ nhất là đậu đúng không
Biển trung bình phải mở két ra lớn hơn
hoặc 36 nóng bằng kép lại phải tiếp theo
là gì Excel người nữa Nam đúng không
phải đoạn mở Hoặc ra lớn hơn 5 đóng
ngoặc kép phải tiếp theo điều kiện ba là
vuốt lớn lớp 8 quá phút này
em phải gặp mở két dao động nhiên lớn
hơn 8 gọi nó kép dấu ngoặc đơn ạ hoặc
enter là nó sẽ bằng không Bây giờ không
phải buốt lớn 8 đi mà buốt lớn hơn cá
mày cao lớn hơn 6 đi thích và đã bị word
lớn Sáu đi
ở lại thì lúc này có 3 thí sinh đã như
vậy Ở đây là có ba điều kiện nếu như mà
hút được hơn 6 nhé cái cậu thích đúng
rồi đây ví dụ lớn hơn 60 thì như vậy là
có 3 thí sinh tất cả đúng không Ok như
vậy mình đã xong cái phần câu hỏi của
bài số 4 nhé còn đóng lại thì ở đây mình
sẽ không lưu còn các bạn thì bọn lưu bạn
Ok sang bài số 5 các bạn thích vào đây
Các bạn thấy nhất nếu như bạn nào không
biết cách mà tải cái file thực hành về
đấy thì các bạn xem lại cái bài đầu tiên
nhá trong bài đấy mình đã hướng dẫn chi
tiết cách để tải file về rồi đó bây giờ
mình sẽ kích vào đây để mình mở file lên
Ok mình sẽ bảo cái sức nội dung thì
trong bài học hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn
các bạn là bốn cái phần đầu tiên là khi
nào thì mình sử dụng hàm ít và cú pháp
của hàm ếch công nghiệp cách sử dụng
hàng VIP đơn và ít lòng nhau và kết hợp
với các hàng khác và ở đây cụ thể là Hà
men và bong á mình sẽ vào cái phần chi
tiết rồi khi nào thì mình sử dụng hạt ít
khi giá trị của một gen phụ thuộc vào 1
anh ở đây mình sẽ làm cái ví dụ nhắc đến
và tổng giá lớn hơn 100 thì giảm giá 10
phần trăm còn không có đi không giảm giá
đấy thiệu đây mình đã có hai cái ví dụ
rồi nếu như mà tầm giá 105 đúng không
Chắc là lớn hơn 100 thì sẽ là giảm giá
10 phần trăm còn trong trường hợp và
tổng giá nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng 100 rất là ví
dụ đây bằng 30 thì cái giảm giá sẽ là
không phần trăm đấy đấy là cái yêu cầu
bây giờ mình sẽ dùng cái hàm gì thì mình
sẽ phải dùng làm ít đúng thì cú pháp của
Hà mít sẽ gồm ba thành phần đầu tiên là
cái biểu thức lôgic Tức là ví dụ ở đây
nhắc mình phải so sánh trong là cái tổng
giá so với 100 đúng không Nếu bạn nó lớn
hơn đấy thì vẫn sẽ trả về cái kết quả
Chu này và ngược lại đứa nhỏ hơn hoặc
bằng 100 thì mình sẽ trả về kết quả khô
là đạt bây giờ mình sẽ làm đấy bài này
nhá ví dụ tổng giá đây đúng không Đấy và
cái giảm giá này còn đây là cái biểu
thức lôgic nhá lại thì cái giảm giá này
đấy bạn thích đút vào đây còn kiểm tra
này thì đầu tiên các biểu thức lôgic nhá
là nó sẽ So sánh cái H9 với cả 100
về chất so sánh kết tổng giá ở đây với
cả 100 để sang cái phần này diện nếu như
mà cái tổng giá này lớn hơn 100 thì nó
sẽ trả về là giảm giá 10 phần trăm đây
đúng không Còn đây là diện nếu như mà
cái tổng giá này không lớn hơn 100 tức
là nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng 100 thì mình sẽ trả
về kết quả Không phần trăm thì trong cái
ví dụ đây cái tổng giá bán ở đây là 30
nó nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng 100 thì đâm ra nó
sẽ trả về cái quả không các bạn enter là
bạn thấy được không bây giờ ví dụ là 105
nhé đấy còn thấy như nó sẽ bằng chu Tại
vì sao 105 nó sẽ lớn hơn 100 đứng ra nó
sẽ trả về kết quả ở cái tham số thứ hai
cho Hà mít này và lưu ý Tu Đúng rồi đấy
là cái cách sử dụng và Mít Ok mình sẽ
vào một cái ví dụ cụ thể trong cái bài
học hôm nay nhá thì mình sẽ có khá nhiều
ví dụ để mình làm quen với cái Hà mít ở
đây giả sử mình có danh sách là cái sinh
viên nên là giới tính ngày sinh ngoại
hình đầy đạo đức và đây là điểm trung
bình câu thứ nhất là mình phải xác định
xem là đội chuyển ở
có điều kiện ở đây ghi là gì Điểm trung
bình lớn hơn hoặc bằng 7 là đỗ không thì
trượt đúng không Lại gọi sẽ bằng này các
bạn tấn pháp này biểu thức lôgic là diện
chính là cái điểm trung bình dưới đây mà
yêu cầu đây là diện lớn hơn hoặc bằng 7
đúng không mà lớn hơn hoặc bằng 7 thì
phải Nếu nhưng mà lớn bằng 7 đúng không
Thì cái giá trị trả về nước đúng là thì
bạn sẽ ghi là gì đỗ đỗ vào các bạn sẽ
tích trữ ít nhé hoặc gọn Huy chế độ ra
được lại phải ngược lại thì là gì ngược
đã chắc là nó không lớn nó bằng 7 nghĩa
là nhà văn bản thì bạn thành như là
trượt gái gọi nó hoặc ép nó hoặc đơn ạ
Gọi enter lại như vậy bạn này là 8,5 lần
đúng không Bây giờ các bạn sẵn tích vào
cái góc dưới bên phải có tích lũy vào
đâu đấy thì như vậy chỉ có duy nhất bạn
hãy chưa Thôi vì bạn này là được 6 điểm
lại Bởi Ví dụ ở đây 7 và mình sửa đấy
xấu nhá các bạn thấy chứ nó sẽ thành
chưa bây giờ ở đây lại 7 đây là đỗ xanh
cái câu hỏi thứ hai là trưởng thành nhá
bây giờ từ 18 tuổi trở
anh là trưởng thành đúng ạ cái trưởng
thành thì mình tính tuổi nhá thì đầu
tiên mình phải xác định được cái năm
ngay tức là năm của cái ngày hiện tại
cái này hiện tại thì ở đây mình sẽ dùng
hàm Today là nó sẽ bằng cái hành tung
đây hãy gọi đến Top này họ sẽ đóng ngoặc
đơn luôn thì cái hạn Today nó sẽ trả về
ngày hiện tại đúng không người hiện tại
ví dụ cách ngày mà mình đang ghi cái
video này là ngày ngày mùng 8 tháng 10
đây này Đây tháng trước ngày sau đúng
không Bây giờ để đến 5 nhá thì bạn sẽ
dùng cái Hà Mi a i a của Cái ô này thì
nó sẽ trả về cái khoảng năm rồi con sẽ
đóng ngoặc lại lại thì nó sẽ trả về 2020
nữa Còn nếu như bạn bằng này các bạn lấy
cái thằng kia của cái năm sinh của các
bạn này là oc3 thời hạn sẽ ra gì hai
nghìn bốn này gọi lên từ đấy thì nó sẽ
hai nghìn lẻ một thì như vậy cái số tuổi
đây sẽ bằng gì bằng lên năm ở đây này
Các sẽ - cái nhau mà Đây đó họ hiểu cái
công thức tính tuổi con đây mình sẽ lấy
cái Hà Mi A của cái này tôi đây mình -
cái hả Mia của cái ngày sinh này mình sẽ
ra được số tuổi và mình sẽ so sánh với
cả
từ 18 tuổi trở lên đúng không Lại ở đây
mình sẽ bằng này ít nếu như mà diện đầu
tiên mình lấy 5 hiện tại nha các bạn để
ý là của mở ngoặc của cái hàm Today nó
gọn Xem mở ngoặc đơn dấu ngoặc đơn là
xong hàng to đây này các bạn đóng ngoặc
đơn để 60 Hà Mi A thì như vậy kia của
các hạt Today này là lấy được cái năm
nay ví dụ Năm nay mình đang làm cái này
là 2020 nó sẽ trả về kết quả 20 20 Thế
bạn - gì ạ - của khách hàng is a các
loại đơn sát nhé yêu của cái năm sinh
của các bạn này là ở lấy ví dụ là 2000
không thì 2020 và - 2000 được bằng 20
đấy con sẽ đóng mọc lại là xong cái Hàm
Yên này nếu như cái biểu thức này mà
diện lớn hơn hoặc bằng bằng 18 đấy thì
cần phải có trả về kết quả gì là trưởng
thành đúng không Ví dụ là tê tê là
trưởng thành đúng không có sự đóng ngoặc
kép lại phải nếu như ngược lại mà không
lớn bằng 18 tuổi là nhỏ 18 do cảm ứng
của mụn màu hoặc ghép các bạn sẽ ghi lại
diện chưa trưởng thành chưa TP đi lại đã
sợ đó
cả các bạn ạ Gọi enter lại như vậy bạn
là trưởng thành đúng không Tại vì Năm
nay là năm 2020 và - 2000 thì nó sẽ ra
là 20 tuổi vẫn tiếp bước vào đây Đấy như
vậy Ở đây có từng đấy bạn trên trưởng
thành năm bạn trên trưởng thành nhá tiếp
theo là gì mình sẽ xác định yêu hay
không yêu ở đây mình làm theo vui một tí
nhá thì nếu như ngoại hình xinh thì là
yêu đúng không lại nó chỉ có một điều
kiện cho yêu này thì bảng ý nếu như mở
ngoặc 2 biểu thức lôgic Ở đây các bạn sẽ
thích là cái phần gọi hình giờ đây là
Yuri hay này bóng bằng diện bằng màu kép
là xinh có sẽ đóng hoặc kẹp lại còn phải
lại thì Cậu chả phải gọi là yêu còn nóng
và khép lại phải ngược lại không sinh
đúng không Thế là xấu lạ thì khi là gì
không yêu họ đóng ngoặc kép đó bạn đơn
lại enter hiệu bạn này xinh đúng không
điều không ai có thể đưa vào đây như vậy
có bốn bạn là yêu nhé Bốn Bạn là không
yêu tiếp theo là liệu mình sẽ làm với
sếp loạn thì cái xếp loại này thì mình
tủ bếp lò nhau nhé nếu như vậy điểm
trung bình nhỏ hơn năm thì là kém nhỏ
hơn 7 thì là trung bình và nhỏ hơn 8 thì
đặt khá còn lại là giỏi đúng không Đấy
thì mình sẽ loại đầu tiên họ sẽ bằng ít
à nếu như vậy điểm trung bình chọn sẽ
tích vào cái ô F2 lần mà rẻ đầu tiên là
ngắn năm đúng không cần phải cao bạn sẽ
trả về kết quả gì Các bạn yếu còn đóng
ngoặc kép lại phải ngược lạ Nếu như
không phải nhỏ nằm đúng là Cọ lại lồng
thêm một cái mít nữa Nếu nhưng vẫn là
cái cái F2 này và diện nhỏ hơn 7 phải
cần phải cắt mổ ghép các bạn trả về cả
là trung bình TP còn đấu hoặc em lại
phải mình nhận thêm một cái ít nữa ngược
lạ mở ngoặc Nếu như mà Rịa vẫn là cái
điểm trung bình này và nhỏ ấn 8 thì là
khá đúng không nhỏ hơn tám còn phải phát
nổ và ghép lại bọn chẳng thấy bà khát
nấu và phép ạ Vẫn phải thì ở đây còn lại
mỗi môi trường ở cuối cùng thôi tức là
trường hợp còn lại thì là giả
em không cần phải thêm hạt mít nào nữa
tao mở ra gọn sẽ ghi là giỏi chọn đóng
ngoặc kép lại bạn đóng học lại đưa này
để xong hạt mít thứ ba là dòng đơn lại
để xong rồi ý thứ 2 đóng ngoặc đơn lại
Để sau nhà bếp đầu tiên gặp enter thì
như vậy bạn để nó sẽ ra là giỏi đúng
không có thích lúc này Đấy 8,5 lần giỏi
7 là khá 7,5 lần khá là tán là do đại có
mỗi bạn này thôi là trung bình còn lại
toàn khá mới do tiếp theo là mình phải
xác định mục tiêu đấy nhá đầu tiên được
gì ở đây mình sẽ có ba cái mục tiêu yêu
với điều kiện là gì ạ điều kiện là hạnh
kiểm tốt người điểm chúng mình lớn 7 và
xinh đấy thì như vậy đây mình phải dùng
cái Hà men nhá mình làm em thì mình xem
là gì ba cái điều kiện thì có thỏa mãn
hay không Nếu bạn điều kiện để thỏa mãn
thì mình sẽ mình rất yêu đúng không biết
dùng cái hộp em để mình xác định này
tiếp theo là diện làm bạn với điều kiện
là gì nếu như mà không phải là người yêu
hoặc là
Ừ đợi thì ở đây mình sẽ dùng cái hả mong
á thì ngược lại của cái hạt ít này mình
sẽ thêm với hàm oở đây đây và cuối cùng
là cái đạo đức kém thì mình sẽ không
chơi không yêu mà cũng không làm bạn và
mình cũng không chơi luôn đấy nó Tức là
cái mục tiêu của mình chỉ có ba cái mục
tiêu một vợ yêu hay là bạn và ba là
không chơi thì trước khi bắt đầu mình
cho giới thiệu qua về các bạn về cái hầm
lôgic để gọi xóa này đi đầu tiên là cái
hòm em thì các bạn hàm em ấy thì đây là
men nó có các biểu thức lôgic thì ở đây
gì ạ Nó chỉ là các biểu thức lôgic thôi
nó sẽ trả về kết quả Chu nếu như tất cả
các biểu thức lôgic ở đây là đúng khoản
là mo thì lại ngược lại đó trả về biểu
thức chu Nếu như một trong các biểu thức
lôgic ở đây là đúng còn ngược lại thì nó
sẽ trả về kết quả ngược lại nhé các bạn
bạn này Ví dụ ở đây mình em tắt mở ngoặc
em Nếu như mình xác định đã yêu chẳng
hạn thế nhá thì gì ạ đạo đức phải bằng
tốt đúng không Này Đạo Đức ở đây bảng
diện mở két là tốt chọn đó hoặc
ở địa điểm trung bình lớp bằng 7 hội
điểm trung bình người ta lớn hơn hoặc
bằng diệt bằng 7 phẩy và diện ngoại hình
xinh tới bằng này mở hoặc sinh ông mày
hơi bị yêu cầu cao bạn có con yên tâm
thì bạn thấy nó trả về Chu Thì bạn này
chắc chắn yêu rồi đúng không đấy bạn này
có mỗi bạn là yêu thôi Đây chúng mình
đến bài đạo đức tốt và xinh quá yêu luôn
đúng không ở đây mình xác định o nhé lại
như vậy còn lại ở đây là 6 ông này bởi
ông này là không thể yêu được rồi thì
mình xem là bảy ông này Xem không nào
chơi được nhé Đúng không Ở đây cái ao là
gì mình xem cái phần Điều kiện thứ Hai
nhé không phải là người yêu hoặc là đạo
đức trung bình tức là gì nếu như mà
không phải là người yêu và đạo đức là
trung bình hoặc là tốt đúng không Chúng
mình mà làm bạn được thì tốt phải làm
bạn chứ Thì mình chỉ cần bằng này các
bạn cũng lo ở đây Các mở ngoặc họ thì
được xem đạo đức này có bằng mở ngoặc ra
là
ở trận đấu hoặc ép bạn phải hoặc là diện
Đạo Đức ở đây mở bằng mở ngoặc kép là
trung bình các đóng ngoặc kép dấu ngoặc
đơn lại gặp enter là xu thì riêng đã yêu
rồi thì mình không tính rồi đúng không
yêu này bây giờ phôi nhé Thì những ông
này Chu này là bạn này Chu là bạn Chu là
bạn Sau đó bạn thứ hai cái phone này
iPhone là vì xem lại đấy kém kém như vậy
là mình hai ông này nó không chơi nữa
bây giờ mình sẽ làm nhé mình xóa cái này
đi đây là mình viết cho các bạn để hiểu
cái hay cái hàng lôgic là men vào thôi
nhé cậu sẽ bằng đầu tiên là ít nếu như
mà gì Các bạn sẽ dùng cái Hà mint + mở
ngoặc thì ở đây là gì đầu tiên mình sẽ
yêu trước nhá đầu tiên hạnh kiểm tốt
đúng không Mà đã lúc tốt là E2 Bà Nguyệt
mở két ra là tốt đâu mà khép lại phải
biểu thức lôgic thứ hai là điểm trung
bình lớn đẩy quá điểm trung bình ở đây
lớn hơn bằng 7 phẩy cái biểu thức luôn
Thứ ba là phải xinh hơn đúng không ngoại
hình ở đây à
ở Brazil đóng ngoặc kép đóng nắp đỡ nặng
Nếu như mà em thấy rất là thỏa mãn ba
cái điều kiện này thì cần phải trả về
kết quả hiện là yêu hay là nó khép lại
phải ngược lại không yêu tức là một
trong ba cái điều kiện này không thỏa
mãn nó cậu sẽ ít thêm nữa bây giờ bạn sử
dụng với Hà ngon nhá Nếu như Bà Rịa thứ
nhất là không phải người yêu này ở đây
phải làm và chứ không phải là hoạt được
và đạo đức là lớn vòng trung bình cơ thì
ở đây là o diện Đạo Đức ở đây thì mình
sẽ ghi là gì Đạo Đức ở đây bằng việc mở
ngoặc kép ra là tốt cậu sân đấu khép lại
phải gửi cho tôi thích thứ hai là dị vẫn
là E2 ở đây bằng tốt hoặc là bằng trung
bình đúng không trung bình họ nó khép
lại còn đóng ngoặc đơn để xong là mong á
phải Nếu như mà thỏa mãn một trong hai
điều kiện này các bạn sẽ trả về Cái bản
gì là bạn đã cạn dấu ngoặc kép lại phải
còn lại gì Các bạn mở ngoặc là không
chơi à
Có thể bạn sẽ đóng ngoặc kép dấu ngoặc
đơn lại đã hạn vip thứ 2 đóng ngoặc đơn
ở sau hãy đầu tiên đã ra Master nhận
lãnh thuế nhà ở đây không phải là hoặc
độc vào đây phải là và đấy không yêu mà
không yêu không ạ và đã Đức lớn và bằng
trung bình nhé Mình ghi là lớn vào trung
bình để cho dễ hiểu tốt là trung bình mà
lại thì đoạn tích ở đây còn tính độ và
đây đấy như vậy Có mỗi bạn đã yêu thôi
còn hai ông này nó không chơi tại vì sao
ông này là đạo đức kém không chơi được
kể cả sinh đây là giỏi mà cứ đạo đức kém
là mình không chơi lại quan điểm là như
vậy nhé Thì Ok mình sẽ xong cái phần này
rồi nhá như vậy mình đã xong cái bài tập
của khách hàng được biết ít lại Bây giờ
mình sẽ xem cái bài tập về nhà cho các
bạn nhá Đang các bạn tích vào giải bài
tập về nhà à
anh đợi cả thứ nhắc cái bài tập về nhà
là gì câu hỏi điền vào cột ghi chú theo
tiêu chuẩn sau lại những học sinh nào có
đạo đức tốt này có điểm trung bình từ 4
trở lên hoặc những học sinh đó có đạo
đức trung bình có điểm trung bình lớn
năm trở lên thì ghi lên lớp còn lại nở
lớp Tức là mình sẽ xác định là bạn nào
nên nước và bạn nào ở lại nước nhá Đây
thì con sẽ làm với bài này cho mình Ok
như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học ngày
hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi
các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật
video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia sẻ
để giúp mọi người cùng học Excel nhé Xin
chào và hẹn gặp lại à